And then I read a lot of books and talked to a lot of a lot of smart people
you're self-taught? yeah.
think about your school experience
You memorize a whole bunch of statistics and random facts and figures that help you pass a test and then
99% of it
vanishes. You can learn more from speaking to people in 15 minutes. Then if you spent your life doing something
Rise and shine it's an spresso time good morning believe nation
It's evan my one word is believe and I believe in you I believe you have an amazing gift inside you that I want to
See exploded onto the world so grab your coffee and sip on today's message
Learn it yourself
Over to you Elon Musk
How did you get the expertise to be the chief technology officer of a rocket ship company
Well, I do have a physics background
that's helpful as a foundation, and then I read a lot of books and talk to a lot of a lot of smart people
you're self-taught? yeah well. It's self-taught. Yes meaning um I didn't I don't have an aerospace degree
So how did you go about acquiring the knowledge well?
I
Like said I had read a lot of books talked to a lot of people and and have a great team
you'll be surprised at how much you can learn when you get rid of the idea that the degree makes the difference?
Think about your school experience you memorize a whole bunch of statistics and random facts and figures that help you pass a test and then
99% of it
vanishes. Where when you are learning something that you know how to apply and is directly applicable to your passion you remember it and so
That allows you to learn really really really quickly you either adopt a mindset where I love this video
You are either Elon Musk, or you are the interviewer?
You are either Elon Musk, and you approach a situation you say I can learn anything. I will be self-taught
I will figure it out. I will read books. I will watch videos
I will teach myself how to do this thing or you're like most people that interviewer who will say you're self-taught
You didn't go to school for this and you need to decide right now
What camp you want to fall into as long as you are in the yourself taught?
Questioning not possible mindset limiting beliefs. You're always gonna be held back
Where if you can adopt the mindset that I can learn anything that I want to I can go up against experts
Who've been doing this for years because I just care more about this thing and when I dedicate myself to something
I will learn it and be amazing at it if that's your approach going in then guess
What who will be I look at my Instagram account as an example
It took me six years to get to six thousand subscribers or six thousand fans something like that six years
Right there abouts and I just never really put a priority on it in the past month. I've grown to by a thousand plus
so six years to get the six thousand one month to get the seven thousand and we're growing and we're growing or growing and I
Haven't talked about my Instagram account
outside of Instagram apart from this now for those guys watching
I would love it if you want to follow me on Instagram my first public appeal, so I've been studying
I've been spending extra time trying to understand the algorithm hashtag usage pictures quotes
frequency all of the things that make Instagram important
understanding stories understanding highlights understanding how to tag within stories
And I'm teaching people on my team how to do it. I had a call the other day with a Instagram expert
This is somebody who gets paid to coach people on how to do their Instagram accounts and when I'm talking to him
I'm talking the same language
I've only been doing this for a week at that time
But because I spent a week immersing myself and understanding what's happened on Instagram I?
Can talk at the same level as someone who's been doing this for years
And it's not to say that I'm some amazing genius
You could do the same thing to
You're just preventing yourself from doing it because you think you need to have years of experience
Because you think you need to have a degree
because you think you need to go to school for this whatever the thing is that you want to learn if
You want to be great at it?
You can be in a really really really short amount of time if you just dedicate yourself to it, and so you need to decide
Do you want to be that Elon Musk and believe that you could teach yourself anything and be a genius at it
Or do you want to be the reporter and always question everything and say you're self-taught
It's not possible. What mindset. Do you want to adopt now?
I've got a special bonus clip for you
But before getting to the bonus clip my question of the day is
What was the last thing that you taught yourself to do that you are really proud of leave it down the comments below
I'm really curious to find out thank you guys so much for watching
I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in yourself, and whatever you're one where it is much love enjoy the bonus clip
And I'll see you again tomorrow morning for another shot event spresso
Learning is a lifelong thing. It doesn't end at Harvard Business School. It's your responsibility. I think if you're in any
Profession at all you have to do it consistently all the time
I think I spend probably fifty or sixty percent of my time learning reading talking to people traveling
That's the only way you can keep on top of this global world of ours
And it's even tougher now because of the globality of the businesses you're all going to deal in
How reading is the most important one?
But the second one which is often forgotten is talking to other people you can learn more from speaking to people in 15
minutes then if you spent your life doing something they can explain it to you
And you can learn from watching people you also are going to learn by I'm gonna call it imitation
But by watching other very good people, and how they operate in difficult circumstances
I learned a lot of things what not to do and a lot of what to do by watching
Other people I had one definition that I have for a good team is a group of people that makes better decisions
as a whole then it would individually make is a sum of the parts and
When you're I think most smart people like learning
Right and I mean that's like one of the thrills of starting a company right is you're just the learning curve can be so steep
And if you can set up a team dynamic where you're constantly learning from the people around you
Then I mean what's better, right?
These are the people I wake up every morning
And I want to I want to go learn from and just from is that one of your heuristics for hiring people to to like
hire people that you learn from
Yeah, and when building a team you want it to you want to think about the dynamic so that way you can maintain this property?
That the team makes better decisions as a group than any individual would
But like these charts only like no
Sing good, but we're gonna get you a boat approaching. You know I'd always be like no I'll teach myself
I honestly personally I
Sucked at singing it when I was like 17 like I was awful horrible
I was the worst singer like this is all a bad singers out there. I was horrible so you're right
and every single day I would listen to John Legend and
I would go on the back of the city bus cuz I was very shy singing late
And I couldn't come in front of somebody in sing
It's very nerve-racking to sing yes what I would do is I would go on the city bus and go to the back back back
Now it's similarly loved
Just when people were there no matter what anyone a diary that would sing really though
Then I got a little bit started singing a little high
For me, but I was just thinking you would like you have a pretty voice the muscles my vocals I
Started getting stronger, and I made on me Father
You know singing is one of the most
important components to me, so
That's how it all started the reason why I'm
Versatile at singing is because I taught myself and when I was teaching myself
I wanted to try to sound like everything so I could teach myself how to sing this way and sing this way
You know, but never actually I think that became
You know the way I became versus analyzing
The most important work ever if you had to think of one word
That's most important to you or that sums you Apple. That would be like a little beacon
They believe nation if you want to know what the most important one word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a very special secret video for you check the description for details